[Musique]
qu'on rentre dans la sphère l'assassin
la fin n'était tropicale et
à quelques lieues du mont tremblant une
serre chaude et humide abrite une plante
rarement cultivés ici l'athlète est
vraiment magnifique ça fait très est
tropical effectivement qui a le
potentiel de devenir encore plus hall
au pied de ce beau feuillage exotiques
du gingembre
fraîchement sorti du sol oui
contrairement aux gens qu'on a pu voir
en épicerie c'est un bébé jambiers est
encore tout jeune y oppose sa peau
extérieure dit encore segal fatigué car
aux puits sont peu juste frotter avec
les doigts et ses petits zekkal le
concernant les viandes souvient jean qui
est vraiment l'eau tout en grain épais
possible rue à ce stade si nous y sommes
vraiment très juteux
la ferme aux petits oignons offre du
bébé gingembre à ses 900 abonnés le
panier bio et dans les marchés
avoisinants on est toujours à la
recherche aussi de nouveaux produits
pour satisfaire nos abonnés nos familles
on est un vrai mec se produit là c'est
sûr que les gens ont vraiment tripé de
pouvoir remplacer un produit importé de
leur panier d'épicerie par quelque chose
a produit localement est non seulement
de produire localement mais quelque
chose de vraiment différent qui se
retrouvaient pas du tout alex très
rares sont les femmes qui réussissent à
faire pousser ici du gingembre une
dizaine ou québec véronique en est elle
à sa sixième saison c'est jean bleu ya
sept mois on n'est pas capable de se
rendre au stade où le linge en est
mature aux formes issa pouye course à
conserver parce que si on arrive dans
l'hiver puis là c'est plus rentable de
chauffer pour juste pour ça dans toi au
goût tu vois tu une grosse différence en
dessous qui aimait tant de gens bio
contient du pérou par exemple oui les
goûts et plus j'irai florale et un peu
moins apparaît comme une amertume qui se
développe dans le gingembre en
vieillissant conte au pot quand guy
l'argent des jeunes comme ça en eux
plusieurs entreprises qui ont appris qu
on faisait du gingembre donc ce serait
d'être contacté par les micros du terril
et microbrasserie une chocolatière un
programme pas dave dobbin qui reproduit
le ya trois ans un petit lot dessert
avec notre argent
nous avons lancé un défi à la chef fanny
du charme de nous proposer quatre
variations sur le thème du gingembre
avec le bébé gingembre de véronique
c'est comme je te sais plus piqué ça je
m'en allais démontrer que c'est plus
piquant que c'est lui qu'on est habitués
d'acheter un supermarché alors je
commence avec un peu de blanc d'oeuf 1 2
millions de blancs d'oeuf on va penser à
sec comme ça il avait envie de faire un
cocktail un cocktail avec une furie de
pêche link et firent gingembre et mon
sirop de gingembre et feuilles de link
effet un des nuances de jus de citron
annonce de votre cas
une bonne cuillère de purifier l'eau
mettre des glaçons
ni voilà c'est prêt
le
mais c'est drôle que ce soit comme jaune
et rose parce que pas encore fait sa
peau le gingembre nature lui valoir une
peau brune ont vraiment la différence
entre les deux et puis aussi c'est si on
en coupant un morceau on va quand même
la différence de texture ici là toute
seule
cible ils peuvent aussi dès ce moment où
l'iran de dans sa quête du jura quelques
poignées je te quand leur avoue très
fragile tout
septembre ses juteux piquant
que si j'avais dû des méchas dans la
bouche en tout cas ce que ça donne un
tic dans les plats je trouve que c'est
un peu comme live je trouve que quand on
y va avec parcimonie par plat ça peut
donner un petit a indiqué qu'il found
parce que dans la cuisine asiatique
c'est très utilisé il souffre rôle un
truc comme ça que les gens mangent dans
les soutes et de légumes aussi qu'on se
rend pas compte que c'est le missile
ouais souvent en vrai un petit goût une
manie aussi qui vient rejoindre toutes
les autres groupes - j'aime beaucoup
j'ai eu comme idée de faire un tartare
donc le chevalier avec du gingembre a
cru qu'on va rentrer dedans avec la
microplaque je vais mettre un petit peu
de rhubarbe et un tiny maison
fanny propose ensuite deux déserts un
sorbet et au gingembre bonbons
je t'ai confirmons gens avec de l'eau de
ceux qui ça devient comme lg double
b oui quand anne du québec gingembre sur
un peu de sport de masse et puis de
l'eau
le gingembre qu'il soit québécois ou
importés se conserve quelques semaines
au frigo mais il se déshydrate
rapidement
vers l'est pour le conserver le plus
longtemps c'est au congélateur parce que
je pense qu'ils rapatrient ils se
gardent de boké ensuite de son peut bien
rap et bien cuisiner
lors de la fontaine avec la rue bab et
puis le gingembre râpé me permettez-vous
que dire c'est comme une petite finale
de gingembre mais le tennis est sa robe
bien
c'est
oui oui c'est ça c'est très
juste un petit peu trop bon ça c'est
vraiment délicieux on arrête mais un
petit petit tremblay dessus comme ça ça
fait vraiment un petit moment avec est
publiée le jour but c'est pas bon
si vous êtes parmi les chanceux à mettre
la main sur le bébé gingembre un produit
local unique sachez qu'il est vendu
autour de 40 dollars 2 kg
pour dire qu'avec le gingembre et l'a
expérimenté ouais faut oser